GREG: TRUMP KEEPS SCORING THE
DEMS STILL BORING, WHAT DID THE
DEMS LEARN FROM IMPEACHMENT.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE CROOKED,
THEY HAVE A LOT OF CROOKED
THINGS GOING, THEY ARE VICIOUS,
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE BROUGHT
IMPEACHMENT.
>> ANYTHING ELSE?
>> MY NUMBERS ARE TEN POINTS
HIGHER BECAUSE OF FAKE NEWS LIKE
NBC.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: THE COUNTRY KEPT DRIVING
DURING IMPEACHMENT IN AMERICA IS
STARTING TO NOTICE, THEY ASKED
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE
THREE YEARS AGO, THEY SHARE 61%
SAID YES, BETTER OFF UNDER
TRUMP, A NUMBER WAY HIGHER,
OBAMA DID NOT GET THE HIGH, NOR
DID BUSH OR CLINTON OR BUSH 41,
TRUMP’S NUMBER IS SO HIGH I CAN
GET A NOSEBLEED READING IT.
THAT WILL BE TOUGH FOR ANY OF
THE CANDIDATES TO BE.
HONESTLY IS TRUMP GOING TO WORRY
ABOUT THE.
>> IF I WORK FOR TEXAS I MAY SAY
DONALD TRUMP IS SCARED AS A CAT
AT THE DOG POUND.
BUT SINCE I AM FROM NEW YORK, I
PUT IT THIS WAY, WE ARE SCARING
THE LIVING HELL OUT OF HIM AND
WERE JUST STARTING RIGHT NOW.
GREG: I DON’T THINK TEXANS SAY
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
AND I DON’T THINK TRUMP IS
SCARED OF THAT.
EVEN CNN KNOWS THE TRUMP VICTORY
IN NOVEMBER IS NOT THAT HARD TO
GET THERE.
>> IT IS NOT THAT HARD TO GET
THERE BECAUSE NORK CAROLINE IS A
SWING STATE, THEY TEND TO LEAN
RED, FLORIDA IN RECENT ELECTIONS
RINGSLIENS RED AND PRESIDENTIAL
POLITICS, ARIZONA, DEMOCRATS
THINK THEY CAN WIN, LET’S SEE,
IT LEANS RED, THOSE THREE STATES
GIVE THE PRESIDENT 259, LOOK AT
THE MATH HE COULD GET THERE
EASILY WINNING PENNSYLVANIA
AGAIN, THAT WOULD GET HIM OVER
THE TOP LET’S SAY GOES BLUE,
PRESIDENT COULD GET THERE BY
WINNING MICHIGAN AGAIN, THAT CAN
GET IT OVER THE TOP YOU COULD DO
IT WITH ACCOMMODATION OF NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND WISCONSIN, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE MAP NOW THE
PRESIDENT HAS A VIABLE PATH.
GREG: YOU CANNOT HEAR IN THE
BACK DON LENNON QUIETLY WEEPING.
[APPLAUSE]
THE DEMS BETTER FIND SOMETHING
ELSE TO INVESTIGATE LIKE TO
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP
INTERFERING IN THE ROGER STONE
CASE WITH THE TWEET.
BUT TRUMP TWEETS ALL THE TIME
WHICH MEANS HE INTERVIEWS AND
EVERYTHING.
MIKE BLOOMBERG A MASSIVE DEBT
ENERGY.
[LAUGHTER]
NEW STOCK MARKET RECORD, SPEND
YOUR MONEY WISELY.
[LAUGHTER]
A LINEUP ON FOX TONIGHT WITH
JESSE WATTERS, JUDGE JEANINE AND
GREG GUTFELD.
[CHEERING]
GREG: THAT’S A REAL QUICK TWEET,
YOU NAME IT HE IS GOING TO TWEET
IT, THE DEMS ARE TRYING TO
IMPEACH TRUMP WITH ALL THEY HAVE
EXPRESSION WITH THE MAJORITY
SAYS THE BETTER OFF WHEN 90%
THINKS MY LIFE IS GOOD, WHEN THE
FIRST IMPEACHMENT DID NOT PUT A
SINGLE DENT IN TRUMP’S ARMOR,
WILL THEY TRIED AGAIN, I HOPE SO
BECAUSE I REALLY MISS ADAM
SCHIFF.
>> SLIDE DOWN A MOUNTAIN IN MY
BARE FEET.
>> READY OR NOT HERE I TEST,
READY OR NOT.
>> HAVE THEY CALLED SECURITY.
>> I SAY I HAVE THE LIGHT, I
RECOGNIZE MYSELF, GOOD NIGHT.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: ROB, THOUGHTS IN GENERAL,
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING.
>> IN GENERAL I KNOW PRESIDENT
TRUMP, HE CAN NEVER NOT SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT ME, HE BROUGHT
ME TO THE LINCOLN BEDROOM, I’M
LOOKING AT THE GETTYSBURG
ADDRESS AND I TURN AROUND AND HE
SAID ROB NOT EVERYBODY GETS TO
SEE THIS UNLESS YOU’RE DONATING
TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU JUST CANNOT.
>> IT’S FUNNY, HERE IN BLOOMBERG
TALK, I LIKE TO MAKE JOKES ONCE
IN WHILE, MY NUMBER ONE JOKE IS
NEVER ABOUT POOP BUT ALWAYS
ASSAULT NUMBER TWO.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
ANYTHING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT WAS A PRETTY GOOD JOKE.
>> FOR ALL OF THE MONEY THAT
BLOOMBERG HAS, HE CANNOT HAVE
FOUND A COMEDIAN COACH.
IT CAN BE 250,000, ALL DO THE
JOKES FOR YOU.
HE LITERALLY SAID IN TEXAS HE
WAS MORE NERVOUS THAN A CAT AT A
DOG POUND.
[LAUGHTER]
WHY, ALL THE DOGS ARE LOCKED UP.
AND THEN HE WAS LIKE, HOW ARE WE
DOING IN NEW YORK, AND THE CROWD
WAS LIKE HOW DO YOU DO NEW YORK?
THE ENTIRE PLACE WAS LIKE --
WHEN SOMETIMES WHEN PEOPLE TALK
AND THEY CANNOT TELL A STORY, IT
HURTS SO BAD YOU CANNOT LOOK AT
THEM.
I GUARANTEE YOU THE ENTIRE
AUDIENCE BY THE TIME HE GOT DONE
WERE LIKE -- AND THEN YOU HAVE
TO LOOK BACK TO ACKNOWLEDGE
BECAUSE HE’S LOOKING AT YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
LET’S GO.
WHEN YOU DON’T HAVE CHARISMA OR
TALENT IN YOUR REBELLION OR, YOU
BUY IT.
I’M ON SALE I’LL GET UP THERE.
GREG: I THINK HE IS PAYING FOR
IT BUT HE’S GETTING LOUSY JOKES.
>> I THINK SO TOO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT IS SO WEIRD.
>> BECAUSE HE PROBABLY HAS
SOMEBODY TO FEED HIM ICE
CREAM --
>> I WOULD THINK ABOUT VOTING
FOR A GUY THIS IS THAT IF I’M
YOUR PRESIDENT THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN, AND SOMEONE FEED YOU ICE
CREAM AND THERE’S A GIANT
GINGERBREAD FLIPPING AROUND.
AND HIM RIDING A BIG GIANT CAT
THAT HE MADE FROM A DINOSAUR.
GET THINGS DONE.
INSTEAD WE GET A CAT AND A DOG,
STEERS AND COWBOY HATS,.
GREG: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IS IT MY TIME TO TALK?
[LAUGHTER]
I’M PRETTY SURE THEY JUST TALKED
OVER ME THE WHOLE TIME.
BUT THAT WAS GOOD.
>> I ENTERED DID I HEAR THAT
RIGHT?
I’M AMAZED.
>> PIRATES ENTERPRISEPIRATES, I
IT WORSENED IN 2016.
EVERY TIME I CAME ON THE SHOW,
USED TO DO HILLARY WHEN SHE
WOULD SAY, BOY I WANT TO TELL
YOU AND SHE WOULD DO THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> REMEMBER GOING TO THE POLLS.
>> ALL BLOOMBERG HAS TO DO IS
BOY HE’S ABOUT AS SCARED AS ME
AS A CAT AND A DOG POUND AND HE
GET THE HILLARY INVENTION.
>> TRUMP IS FUNNY.
WHETHER YOU LIKE HIM OR DON’T
LIKE HIM, HE IS OBJECTIVELY
HILARIOUS AND YOU WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO BE FUNNIER THAN HE IS.
>> THAT IS A GOOD POINT, YOU
SHOULD BE THE GUY.
[APPLAUSE]
THAT IS NOT FUNNY.
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
ACTUALLY GREAT HUMORLESS PARTY,
THE PARTY OF THE HUMOR.
GREG: BLOOMBERG VERSUS TRUMP, A
TORTOISE VERSUS THE HAIR, HE
LOOKS LIKE A TORTOISE AND TRUMP
HAS THE HAIR.